[Music]
are there any fun German traditions you
can tell us about that I might like to
go to Germany somebody I do travel my
show occasionally and maybe I would like
to go there please I will be your
Tenzing Norgay you may be my Edmund
Hillary
we will walk around and have raisins and
peanuts please please freeze that and
google it that's that's fantastic I
would love to do that what do you will
so what would we do we would we would
what kind of things do we do what do
Germans do for fun we would awake at
very early in the morning have the birds
trip or the birds or the worms out no we
have beaten the worms they are still
snoozing away Conan and we are running
around and we go to early bird the word
early bird catches the worm where's no
the worm isn't sleeping oh we don't know
what mean we don't know is the worm lazy
is it a self-motivated worm we don't
what is this PC up worm - awesome
slovenly worms ok it's just it's so
early that the worms have been eaten yes
got enough I get it yeah yeah so so
punctual yeah so so what happens when we
get up really early what are we doing we
wake it up we eat some muesli
immediately we put some yogurt in the
muesli yogurt okay oh it is a delicious
combinations like peanut butter and
peanut buddy and you know like a jello
then we go for a hike it's called a
false March which means people's March
people's won't smart oh yeah and we walk
for ten kilometres exactly okay and
every 2.5 kilometres there is an old man
in a tiny boy and a dog on a bench and
say give you a stamp to make sure you
have done the walk little boy why can't
this be the old man the boys excited to
see you so you roughly - here's a boy
oh I said the old man had cold cold
tears for you and the dog is smoking all
of the trips that you have done is you
are drinking about so everything has
everything it's just about getting this
way - fine what can you get with the
stamp when you turn the stamp in what do
you get after the fourth stamps you
receive a plaque a trophy or a large
piece of cake I would very much like to
go to Germany xev maybe I could come to
Germany with you I will join you and you
will join me we would be like a
three-legged sack race but with no sack
and it's not a race we will take our
time
[Applause]
you